tonight though we are honored and
delighted to have David gold pills with
us David from a wonderful book that came
out last year that has gotten lots of
attention called catastrophic care a
American health care killed my father
and how we can fix it David received a
BA in history from Harvard a MA in
history from NYU
he's president and chief executive
officer of the game show network which
operates u.s. cable TV network a u.s.
cable TV network seen live in seventy
five million homes and is one of the
world's largest digital games companies
he's in there was a board of directors
of a leapfrog group an entire sponsors
organization dedicated to hospital
safety and transparency he wrote this
book inspired and I'm sure here by his
own family experience he wrote an
article of the Atlantic that got a lot
of attention and then led to this book I
decided to be great to have him speak
this evening because he provides a lot
of interesting perspectives both based
on his own personal experience on his
reading on what it's like to be a family
member on the perspective some who's
been involved in the business community
in many ways and also the fact that
anyone can have an impact on these
important debates that are taking place
in our country today youtube can write
an article
perhaps a book and help influence a
discussion so without further ado please
welcome David gold
thank you and thank you for choosing to
spend this Laureus day of an unexpected
heatwave inside i'm from the small but
growing minority of people who look at
our health care system and suspect that
a lot of the problems that have grown up
over the last two decades our result of
our is assuming that health care is so
different from everything else so
different from every other business
activity so different from every other
consumer activity then it requires its
own economy and the argument i make in
in my book and in articles is that this
economy sends all the wrong signals to
providers and to consumers it encourages
a massive amount of overuse it
discourages prices from disciplining the
system as it doesn't everything else it
impedes the right type of innovation
encourages often the wrong type of
innovation and then most directly and
most immediately in in my family's case
encourages a culture of sloppiness that
is truly different than anything else we
see now you know as I mentioned it's a
minority viewpoint but it's growing and
it's growing not just in this country
but in others as we recognize that many
of the assumptions we have about health
care are twentieth-century assumptions
maybe even 19th century assumptions and
the world has changed Healthcare is
grown to become our largest industry our
single largest source of consumption it
is no longer what it originally was
which was something we use rarely rarely
only when absolutely urgent and only
infrequently with good results health
care has been integrated into our lives
in a way that would have been
inconceivable when any of the health
care systems around the world were
created and yet many of the assumptions
in which those health care systems were
created many the reasons they were
created not only still are conventional
wisdom but dominate the political debate
I'm gonna talk tonight at least a start
about twenty or thirty minutes on a
presentation about what I regard as the
founding myths of health care that have
gone largely unexamined in the the last
two or three generations suggest are no
longer true
and yet they dominate our thinking and
then we can spend 45 minutes I guess
taking questions on game shows but let's
start with health care why am I here I'm
not a health care person I guess I've
sort of become one over the last few
years it's my very time-consuming hobby
and I'm very grateful to my employer
that they let me free for that hobby but
my interest in healthcare started with
what happened to my father my father in
2007 and in November walked in October
walked into a hospital feeling some
shortness of breath but he was quite
healthy went to work that day the
hospital suggested keeping him for
observation overnight unfortunately gave
him a an IV that it looks like gave him
an infection five weeks later without
ever leaving that hospital he was dead
he died of a faction acquired in the
hospital and you know if you've ever
been through this as a family member
even just being with a loved one for an
extended hospital stay you'll notice a
lot of strange things about the way
hospitals work particularly if you spend
any time in the rest of the economy
they're quite disorganized they're not
obvious economies of scale of size
they're not obvious economies of scope
of doing lots of different things
in fact both size and scope seem to hurt
the way hospitals operate if you've got
a loved one in a hospital your physician
is likely to say to you you know it's
best if there's a family member around
at all times because hospitals make
large numbers of mistakes almost
inconceivable mistakes in an error in
which IT runs everything else in our
lives I often use the example of we're
so used to hearing that then we don't
think to ourselves imagine if we took a
package to FedEx and FedEx said we'll
get your package there but it would
really be best if someone stayed with it
along the way and yet none of us are
surprised to hear it would be best if
you have a loved one if you were with
your loved one in the hospital or
somebody was and if you spend five weeks
with a loved one in the hospital even in
an intensive care unit I did with my dad
you'll see him taken for tests meant for
other patients you'll see doctors come
in who have forgotten who he was and
forgotten what the conditions are you'll
see tons and tons of errors it's truly
astonishing and ultimately the biggest
error of all is the
that cost my father his life about four
or five weeks after my dad died Atul
Gawande wrote a piece in The New Yorker
in which he talked about a physician of
Peter Pronovost who's been running
around the country trying to convince
hospitals to adopt a series of protocols
mostly involving washing her hands basic
sanitary stuff that we're had had been
tried had reduced the rate of
hospital-acquired infection deaths by
somewhere between 2/3 and 3/4 and the
cost basically nothing it was
fundamentally cultural and managerial
and I'm a business guy and something
struck me as incredibly and profoundly
wrong about that story go on Dee's piece
is actually a heroic piece about how
part of us does tire listen I've gotten
an Ellen he's careless in pursuing this
but at a completely different
perspective I'd run a movie theater
chain and we'd a rule in this movie
theater chain which is of a soda spilled
and it wasn't cleaned up within five
minutes the manager of that particular
theater was in trouble why well it
wasn't because of liability it wasn't
because we were afraid somebody was
gonna break their neck and sue us it was
for something much smaller it was
because Saturday night business said a
movie theater is date night for young
married couples they invested in the
babysitter they finally get a night out
they come into your movie theater and
they see spilled soda in the lobby it
changes the whole experience well it
means maybe next week they go to a
different movie thing small minimum wage
workforce and yet you can easily get it
done what do you sit about healthcare
that meant that Pronovost was having to
sell desperately sell a series of
protocols that save lives
forget about save money save lives right
we don't get the movie theaters business
we don't get to save lives that often it
struck me as astonishing and it got me
started on what's now six years of work
on the question of what are the
incentives in healthcare why isn't it
automatic and organic that when someone
comes along with a better idea to
improve quality and loose' improve
safety improve efficiency its adopted
and almost all of my work is about that
why those incentives in almost
everything else in life
drive better behavior often in pursuit
of a dollar of profit frankly and in
healthcare don't the major reason I
believe is because we have created this
economy in health care they didn't sense
almost the exact opposite of what we
have and the biggest problem problem
number one is we have the wrong customer
the customer in health care isn't any of
us it's big insurance companies CMS
which is the agency that runs Medicare
and the state agencies to run Medicaid
they are the customer and if you've
worked in enough industries and one of
the benefits of not being able to hold
the job very long as you get to see a
lot of different industries as I have
you see how the actual identity of the
customer determines how you behave those
of you who are students know that either
way you perform in different classes
depends on the other professors who are
your customers it's fundamental but
we've taken ourselves out of that
equation health care we are not the
customer and we all know why because
without insurance health care could
never be in for affordable now that
statement is so obviously false because
clearly all the money to pay for health
care is coming from us it's just running
through insurers almost every economist
will tell you anyone who believes that
employers are really paying health
insurance premiums doesn't know anything
about economics we just sit there and
say how much does an employee cost us
whether we paid insurance premiums
salaries days off is irrelevant it's all
coming from the same place and so one of
the first things they did is go look at
one of my young employees one of gSN's
young employees looked at a 23 year old
woman who was in a good entry-level job
and exactly subtract entry level job
earning now about $35,000 a year this is
two years ago and I asked myself over
her lifetime how much is this woman
she's Becky in my book I'm gonna put
into our healthcare system so she's
obviously gonna pay her share of our
health care frame is we have a very good
health insurance plans like most
entertainment companies it's pretty
strong pretty robust
she's also gonna pay our share cuz it's
just coming out of what we can afford to
pay her over her lifetime she's paying
her deductible out-of-pocket other
out-of-pocket expenses
she's also paying an enormous amount of
taxes she's directly paying Medicare tax
or a tax and now somewhere depending on
the state she lives in between 15 and 30
percent of the total tax that she pays
to state and federal government is gonna
fund health care including some that in
theory she'll get when she's Medicare
eligible so what does it mean for Becky
what it means for Becky is that assuming
she has kind of a typical life gets
married has a couple kids lives till 80
retires at 65 assuming she doesn't get
rich or income grows about three percent
a year which was the average before the
Great Recession and hopefully will be
again and she never gets really sick and
none of her family members get really
sick if the cost of health care goes up
by zero zero for the rest of Becky's
life she will put into the system 1.2
million dollars if it goes up by the
amount that the Affordable Care Act
suggests will happen over the next ten
years if the act is successful in
containing costs she will put in this
number 1.9 million dollars if Becky has
a working spouse together they will put
in two and a half million dollars so
when we say that insurance and Medicare
and Medicaid have made the system
affordable let's think that through has
it what it really done is take money out
of our pockets in a lot of different
places at an enormous amount of
administrative cost to it build in a
tremendous amount of complexity
distortion of the very economy and then
return it when we need it because if you
look at almost everybody in this country
whoever has a job I guarantee you they
are putting far more into the health
care system than they are aware there
are very fits of it just to give you
sense
Becky over her lifetime will learn about
four million dollars in the future value
case where I increase it by 3% a year
and there's
placing all of us so roughly 35 40
percent of that and she's middle-class
she doesn't know right the part she'll
know about is the five seventy right
that's the part that gets people like
Becky to say we need expanded coverage
she doesn't know where that she's paying
it here but there are very very few
families who will put lesson to the who
will put yeah lesson to the health care
system that might take out because a
health care system as a payment system
is the most expensive imaginable payment
system well we all know one of the
benefits is that insurers and Medicare
and Medicaid can drive much better
prices than we can as individuals right
except there are no prices in the health
care system they're entirely fictional
they bear no relationship to the purpose
of prices and anything else right which
is to which is to compensate for real
cost including opportunity cost in the
cost of capital this is the bill that
Medicare sent to my father for the
hospital service of killing my father
six hundred thirty five thousand six
hundred ninety five dollars and seventy
five cents my mother share was nine
hundred ninety two dollars everything in
health care presented like that sounds
like an incredible deal which is why we
do it there are very few places where
you can buy something for six hundred
and thirty thousand dollars for a mere
nine hundred dollars except for the fact
that what they did is they took my
father and looked at him for a day and
then killed him which arguably wasn't
worth that money to us ice know my
mother certainly didn't think it was
worth that money look at these prices
what are they they're nonsense so I did
a little experiment I said let's say dad
was the first Jewish king of Saudi
Arabia and instead what I did is I got
him a room at the Four Seasons a suite
at the Four Seasons was most expensive
hotel in New York and at least all this
hospital equipment put it in this room
gave them round-the-clock nurses gave
him an hour a day to see his physician
gave them room service for all those
meals and this is very important it's
one of the great things about the Four
Seasons TVs free so you don't have to
you know hospitals is nine dollars a day
so that is
as king of Saudi Arabia runs up retail a
bill of a hundred and fifty five
thousand dollars I will tell you the
hospital where dad died was not nearly
as nice as the Four Seasons and the food
was good but this just gives you an idea
of how meaningless this is this tells
you nothing this is useless information
for making any decisions whatsoever well
okay here's what all the conventional
experts say they say yeah yeah yeah
that's all true but the reality is in
health care spending isn't normalized
it's completely random anybody could
have this terrible thing happened to
them and in fact and by the way if you
ever get invited to a health care
conference you want everybody in the
room to nod their head and smile you say
the following you know in any given year
75 65 80 depends on what the number is
that year it's now down to 67% yes of
all health care expenses is accounted
for for only 10% of the population so
you can tell yourself we're all putting
in all this money but what we're really
doing like any insurance system is we're
protecting you against this you're in
that and that sounds persuasive and that
piece of information is now 60 years old
and it's also meaningless here's the
percentage of cars bought by 10% of the
population every year it's a hundred to
8% of us buy all the cars every year
college education weddings refrigerators
vacations divorces you name one of the
things that convinced me that healthcare
economics is an island is that
healthcare economists say this and
seemingly know nothing about the markets
for any other goods and services so
here's how the markets for all expensive
goods and services work if they're
universally used and for the most part
we all buy a car at some point they're
not universally used every year in any
given year 8 9 10 % of us buy all the
cars but we'll all buy cars it's true of
almost everything on Star Trek it's true
of
almost everything that isn't an ordinary
expensive
what makes healthcare unusual totally
different than everything else is that
the other 90% of the population still
spends 33% it's the exact opposite of
what the whole system is based on that's
true
now obviously cars are voluntary
purchase and healthcare feels like it
isn't a voluntary purchase the reality
is some percentage of this 10% is really
sick and it's going to be in that top
10% tiny percentage in the fact
incentive whole lives they're born with
terrible Hollis's another percentage is
sick for a long period of time a
long-lasting cancer treatment for
example but unfortunately or fortunately
almost everybody in this room is going
to have their year in that 10% this
doesn't tell you about concentration of
healthcare spend because it's done on an
annual basis and we live for 80 years
over 80 years this distribution is
almost completely normal with the
outliers thing those who are really sick
but think what we've done we built an
insurance system that covers risk all
risk this is all of it's rare in health
care we've actually built an insurance
system to cover certainty the certainty
that all of us are gonna get sick
imagine if life insurance didn't protect
you against dying early it protected you
against dying at all the premiums would
be greater than the benefit if all of
our homes burned down the only
homeowners insurance you could have is
against burning down this year versus at
some point let's take that analogy a
little further you own a home there's a
chance your home burns down you want to
be insured against that because it's a
one out of 300 chance and a pool of 300
of you bear that risk better what about
the risk of your furniture going out of
style we could argue if we use the
healthcare metaphor we could say well
furniture goes out of style that's a
terrible thing who can afford to replace
all their furniture in one year when it
goes out of style
so let's ensure that - now we know what
happens when we insure everybody
which is everybody's furniture is
constantly going out of style it's what
we've done in healthcare
we've confused the fact that there are
some risks that are rare catastrophic
and major with the way healthcare
started which is that all healthcare
risks felt that way so one of the great
benefits we all know is Medicare and
when you talk to the people about
reforming Medicare this is what they
focus on those Medicare patients about
1617 percent of the Medicare population
that use a lot of healthcare 22,000
dollars a year for this group is current
spending and this is what the healthcare
experts concentrate on how do we get the
spending down by those who are using the
system most intensely don't look at in
the wrong place
we will spend $11,000 $900 eleven
thousand nine hundred dollars a year on
seniors who are in good or fair health
we will spend fifty five hundred dollars
a year on seniors who are in excellent
health what we've done in Medicare is
we've said uniquely in the world by the
way nobody else has a public health care
program as an entitlement they all have
budgets we've uniquely said anything
seniors need will pay for guess how the
industry responded have I got a need for
you and if if you have a parent who's a
senior and my mother is a senior and
obviously my father was a senior it's
extraordinary how much health care they
consume that sounds like a good thing
until you remember Becky because what
we're doing is saying to people like my
mother my mother walks to work in heels
she's foot problems a woman her age who
works is in terrific health her
podiatrist gives her a shot every few
months for her foot problems and has
never said to her have you ever thought
about wearing sneakers when you walk to
work why would he now obviously not all
of the health issues that seniors are
dealing with are that pedestrian to use
a pun when somebody caught it
but in fact if you think about society's
limited resources once you say to any
industry and I guarantee if I said to
the gameshow industry we would respond
we will buy anything you need we will
expand that definition of need look very
closely at what you're seeing your
relatives consume in terms of health
care obviously some are here but there's
a lot of money in here and a lot of it
only makes sense if you don't think
about what that money could have bought
let me tell you my single favorite
Medicare statistic I have never heard a
single politician refer to it in 1965
when seniors paid essentially all of
their health care cost the average
senior for health care expenses of
somewhere around 1011 percent of their
income in 1965 Medicare started in 1966
today's seniors pay roughly 5 percent of
their total health care spending is
out-of-pocket the other 95 percent is
picked up by all of us that 5 percent
the amount they pay is now equal to 17
or 18 percent of their income depending
how you count so what we've done if with
this wonderful benefit is we've expanded
the amount of care they get we've
protected the outliers which I would
argue should have been our goal the
people from true disaster from true
health care problems we've incented
enormous amounts of ends of life care
because you get paid for it why not do
it if you're a hospital they're on
autopilot to do it the most places and
the seniors are paying more than they
were paying before Medicare we spent 5
trillion dollars on that you when I
talked first started talking about
consumers in health care when one of the
bomb administration officials commented
by saying that everyone knows consumers
can't fend for themselves health care
it's impossible and it sure looks
impossible we go out there there are no
prices there no metrics they're often
not there were even directories of
clinics so this man here Kenneth arrow
is a economist at Stanford Nobel
prize-winner and it
really brilliant man and he wrote what's
probably the founding article in
healthcare economics it's 51 years old
this article and what it said was health
care could never be a normal industry
because consumers never know enough they
don't have enough knowledge the doctor
will offer them a service might even say
this is necessary to save your life
what's a consumer gonna do buy so how
can you possibly have the normal
discipline you haven't anything else
where you can say sorry I don't want
that watch I don't want that car I don't
want this meal I'll go somewhere else
you can't do that in health care arrow
set and everybody agrees with that
except every industry is like that none
of us have enough knowledge to buy I
mean some of us are car nuts maybe but
most of us don't buy cars on that basis
let's just don't buy anything on the
basis that's number one
so since arrows work in other industries
there's been tons and tons of work on
how to manage what's called the
information asymmetry which is what he
was talking about where the customer
knows far less than the seller it's true
of almost any industry so that's one but
that's less important than two and three
you many of you may recognize the symbol
of TripAdvisor I served on their board
for a while
it's a terrific company TripAdvisor
rates seemingly every spot of land on
earth now and what's interesting about
what's happened in healthcare is that
the doctor monopoly of information is
long gone when you survey physicians
most of them say that their patients
research significantly and and
healthcare research is one of those two
or three most most used elements of the
Internet most use aspect the Internet in
fact most doctors now tell you you've
got these alternatives so go home do
some research and let's talk more here's
my advice they know you'll do the
research so information asymmetry common
in all industries and handle differently
and less common in healthcare where more
and more of what you do in healthcare is
about choice and less and less is do
this or die the third element though is
a more important argument which is
arrow did not say what the alternative
was he says well if we can get the
government to just buy health care for
everybody that would be great because
the government is not gonna be emotional
about it the government can accurately
say here's what I should have here's
what I shouldn't have some what our
government is done our government has
said you can have anything the doctor
wants and will pay for it's the worst
possible resolution to the point I made
arrow was saying you as a consumer are
going to screw up because the doctors
gonna said you buy this or you'll die
and you're too likely to buy it you're
unlikely to say wait a minute
really I don't believe that and I want
to talk to somebody else and Ida you're
you're - you're unlikely to be skeptical
but how likely to be skeptical if you're
not paying for at all what we've
substituted for this problem has made
the problem far worse so here's what's
happened in markets in which consumers
actually pay you may not be aware but
while medical care for the previous two
decades and physician services UM's
every element in the assured economy
prices grew much faster than inflation
any part of the healthcare economy that
was uninsured grew below the rate of
inflation a lot of you may be familiar
with LASIK
so LASIK had the exact normal price
experience of any new technology was
introduced it was very expensive once a
lot of guys bought the machine serve
their patients prices came down why
because the marginal cost of doing the
LASIK is almost zero and it like most
expensive technologies the marginal cost
of doing an MRI is almost zero and what
happens in normal markets is you buy the
equipment and then once this competition
everybody's trying to get whatever
revenue and amortize it only in
healthcare does high technology lead to
higher prices I don't know how much
leverage you think you're having
cosmetic services but one of the
interesting things is when you look at a
study of a reconstructive procedure done
after a medical procedure and done for
cosmetic reasons often by the same
surgeon right - the same type of patient
the price differentials enormous they
charge much more on the insured market
for the week
construction than they do for the
cosmetic dentists ain't procedure same
everything two different economies
lastly we've substituted insurers for
ourselves because they're so much better
at dealing with this right they have so
much more leverage than we do my son
needed an appendectomy he actually burst
his appendix pretty irresponsible kid so
I wasn't surprised
everything's a problem you know and so
we took him in for an emergency
appendectomy and those of you who are
fortunate enough to have insurance know
this letter if the first letter you get
back whenever you've had a non pre
approved treatment we don't know it was
necessary if my son had been let's say a
dog there would have been other medical
options like having him put down his
mother is very attached to him though
and I must admit we never even
considered that until after I got this
bill from the insurance company who I
thought wow did we rush into that
appendectomy this is what a consumer
economy looks like without consumers you
know when when that guy Tom McDonough
said oh my god can you imagine poor
consumers left on their own this is the
benefit of having someone do the work
for us it's so much harder
I want to be very quick on this point
you know one of the things we think
about all the time it's oh my god I get
hit by a bus what's gonna happen to me
if I have to I can't negotiate you know
if I have a heart attack I'm not gonna
negotiate and of course tons of
industries to figure out ways to deal
with emergency procedures you know you
have a blowout of a tire on a highway it
is a horrible experience and even if you
don't have triple-a or some manufacturer
coverage you know when that guy shows up
to change your tire and you're desperate
and afraid of getting hit by a car he's
not gonna ask you for net worth
statement because there's a market you
have some rough idea for a tire costs
you have some rough idea of what a
service call cost so does he
interestingly what's happened in health
care since Medicare is that even
inpatient procedures of hospitals are
almost never about emergencies anymore
they're about things related to chronic
conditions reconstructive surgeries of
many types if you look about even cancer
by the way is no longer oh my god we've
got to get you in the operating room
tomorrow
the reason cancer centers of america
advertise is because when you have a
cancer diagnosis you have to make a
choice of where and how to be treated
everything in health care well except
for the rare getting hit by a bus
involves choice consideration thinking
about it this this stereotype of getting
hit by the bus is again using the
smallest possible incidents to drive a
whole system it's like we drove the
entire tire market just on blowouts I
talked a bit about Medicare and seniors
I'll spend just one second on this
everybody focuses on the problem of
Medicare is a problem of money until
you've had your parent killed by an
undisciplined health care system and
then you think about this one out of
three Medicare beneficiaries has surgery
in the year of their death even though
the rate of recommended surgery declines
meaningfully as you become a senior
because your opportunity is a risk
reward just changes so much there's
almost never surgery recommended for 90
year olds and yet one out of five
Medicare beneficiaries who dies in their
90s that surgery other death this is
what a system that doesn't face normal
discipline
that's right if you have a senior
admitted to a hospital
there's a one and a half percent chance
that admission is gonna lead to an
accidental - a death from error one out
of every hundred and sixty-five runs the
risk of what's called a never event
which is something considered so sloppy
soap amputating the wrong man wrong
wrong blood things like that should
never happen they happen these rates are
so high they're greater than the rates
of death in combat so here's the big one
right there have been thousands and
thousands of scholarly articles written
on how technology is driving up costs
and health care almost all of these
articles were written on two hundred and
fifty dollar laptops nobody noticed the
iron what's really happening what's
really happening is this this is 1965 in
1965 dec a company that importantly no
longer exists introduced the first mini
computer it was roughly this size this
is a mainframe this is the first
computer design for somebody other than
that saying GM and the Defense
Department write a mere big company
could actually use it to process payroll
so the price of that was nineteen
thousand dollars in 1965 at the same
time the average Americans spent two
hundred fifty dollars on health care
which means that the price of a computer
the most complicated piece of equipment
probably usable by only a few hundred
thousand people worldwide was 80 times
the price to healthcare make sense right
fast forward to today every single one
of you I would bet is carrying in your
pocket
something meaningfully more powerful
than either of those machines many of
you are using them now or wish you were
I'm curious frankly as to what's online
you paid somewhere between two and three
hundred dollars for a top-line one which
is some roughly one thirtieth two 140th
of what the average American will spend
on healthcare this year
how did the most complicated thing on
earth change in price relative to the
most personal accessible by 3,600 times
in two generations what happened do you
really believe it's because technology
drove up the cost of this really here's
what happened it's really simple in this
world everyday men and women wake up in
the morning and say how am I gonna make
my billion I don't wanna do I'm gonna
make it smaller easier to use cheaper
funner more accessible I'm gonna invent
a color no one's seen before I'm gonna
come up with an app that all it does is
enables you to avoid text messaging
charges I'm gonna do this I'm gonna I'm
gonna make it better
simpler more accessible cheaper easier
understanding well here's what didn't
happen the entire population did not get
computer science PhDs so that we could
all use this people made fortunes making
it easier simpler cheaper better nobody
in healthcare can make more money that
way at all no matter what you think if
you really understand the business
models of doctors clinics insurers
hospitals drug companies there is not a
single man or woman who walks into
healthcare industry in the morning and
says I know how to make my billion it's
the Walmart of healthcare it's the low
price leading Hospital that loses money
I know how to make my billion the safest
Hospital on earth you go to whatever
hospital your insurer tells you you have
to go to that doesn't make any money I
don't know how to make more money the
most accessible practice whatsoever you
choose by email you can reach me by
phone you reach me 24 hours a day me or
my partners well insurance don't
reimburse for that can't make money
doing that is money do that every one of
these pluses loses money in the business
model of health care so when you hear
health care experts talk about it's
complicated
technology is difficult love your dry
cleaner adopted information technology
and it wasn't because of the
dry-cleaning IT Act of 1997
it was because your dry cleaner competed
with the dry cleaner across the street
if the reason everybody adopted
information technology this is a place
for information technology would save
lives create enormous efficiencies and
get rid of that chaos you see whenever
you walk into a doctor's office or
Hospital
it hasn't been adopted because no one
makes more money adopting you and what
the government's had to do is say hey
we'll pay for all of it if you had just
adopted but that doesn't change anyone's
incentives if it took you longer to
write a paper on a computer how many of
you would use computers to write your
papers even if the school gave you
computers it still wasn't doing
innovation as a result of this this is
the most important innovation as opposed
where it's a box but doesn't even know
the story the shipping container nothing
has transformed the world economy more
than this and it's the stupidest idea on
earth right because from the beginning
of time the cost of a voyage or the
voyage which were dangerous but scary
and things got lost and so what you do
you pack the ship as efficiently as
possible into a longshoreman did you
just take a week to pack a then
some guy came along said I got a great
idea let's fill ships with space just
air but if we put them on standardized
boxes they can come off ships onto
trains under trucks no one ever has to
unpack you don't have to worry about the
configuration of a ship or you'd have to
worry about the goods just put
everything in box put all the boxes in
there crazy idea right will cost a ton
of money to reconfigure every port on
earth meant that most ships now are
filled with air but by the way that's
why we've had to expand the Panama Canal
because ships are now so large
eliminated hundreds of thousands of
longshoreman jobs and God knows how much
in wages has that went from being a very
skilled profession to a completely
unskilled one or actually a highly
skilled one but operating you only need
five guys to operate cranes and most
ports it's estimated that because of the
effects of the shipping container
particularly the globalization of trade
that a billion people have been lifted
out of poverty roughly 90%
of the world's supply inventory is no
longer needed to be kept near a factory
there's probably nothing that has ever
changed economy as much but I want you
to imagine in health care somebody
walking in with an idea that says I'm
gonna put most people out of jobs who
have them it's going to involve a lot
more upfront cost and it's gonna do
something enormous ly inefficient fill
ships with air what are the odds that
that gets adopted in our healthcare
economy what congressman supports that
that's City Councilman let's that
Hospital they built I want to turn to
one macro issue because it's asked about
all the time that's what we all know
it's this here's another thing that will
get you a lot of nods and health care
conference the left side is life
expectancy and this is percent of GDP
spent on health care and these are the
these are the 30 OECD countries lap down
need let's say this is us we all know
what this means right
this means the United States spends a
lot more money on health care than
anyone else and gets a lot worse result
right so ignore the US thought where's
the line there is none there's no
solution to that you know why because
health care spend has almost nothing to
do with life expectancy when you look at
the factors in life expectancy the big
ones income quality of life which means
diet exercise family structure education
environment all these things way ahead
no matter how you measure who measured
it higher than health care accent right
if you're good on road safety you're
good on guns you save a lot more lives
than health care less there's no
relationship whatsoever no was the last
time you heard a politician say hey I
know spending more in health care has
nothing to do with keeping people on it
is the arguably the least important
factor we can think of when the
Affordable Care Act was passed I wrote
an article that asked a question that
far as I could tell nobody had ever
asked and no one ever answered which is
as a Democrat I get that we want to help
people so we're gonna spend 200 billion
dollars a year on the Affordable Care
Act one hundred billion dollars of
government money the estimate now is
much larger a hundred billion dollars of
people's own money can we think of any
use of two hundred billion dollars that
would have less of an impact than more
ha yeah well that's crazy
right but all health care conversations
are dominated by experts and health care
nobody sits there and says gee maybe we
should spend 200 billion more on how's
it education or parks maybe we should
give everybody a week off or two weeks
off and yet we know particularly at
lower income levels these have a much
greater impact on health this is not the
story of our doing terrible in fact if
you look at the top numbers there it's
Sweden Italy in Japan okay what are
their health care systems have in common
absolute nothing but these people live
like Swedes Italians and Japanese those
are long lasting lifespans the bottom US
and UK what are our health care systems
have in common nothing but we live like
Brits and Americans we we drink we take
lots of risks we do stupid things and
God we watch a lot of TV
so the last myth it's all complicated I
may be the only person who talks about
health care who argues this is wrong
I could spend hours with you debating
all the little things about bundled
payments and fee-for-service and cross
subsidization and all the stuff that
excites most of the debate and inform
most of the Affordable Care Act but it's
really all about this nobody nobody
providing you a health care service has
the right incentive doesn't mean that
people aren't good doesn't mean that
people don't go into medicine or
hospital administration or even health
insurance to do good people do
everywhere there's lots of near saints
in this industry and in some extent
that's confusing to us but we're asking
people when they practice sainthood to
compete against their economic
incentives the economic incentives in
healthcare where you have someone who
will pay for all Meads is do as much as
possible as high a price as possible
that is high a cost as possible because
a lot of guys will reimburse you for
your cost you can imagine what that
doesn't cost and don't waste money of
the things that don't matter
customer service making it easy making
it accessible making it efficient get
paid for that they don't do it a health
care policy involves a lot of those
enormous issues but one of the benefits
that I think people who have my point of
view is that we're all actually
consumers of this and so Daly literally
daily I get an email from someone
tagging you won't believe what happened
to me and it's a story right and we all
have these incredible stories charts
lost doctors who don't coordinate
patients treated for the wrong things
loved ones kept in emergency rooms for
1012 hours what I ask in thinking about
health care is not to think about the
big picture for a second think about the
little picture there's 315 million
little pictures and I've never met
anyone anyone who doesn't have a story
those stories are unique to healthcare
because healthcare is unique because
we've given it a pass we've said it's ok
to be unlike everything else to have
your own world judge by your own rules
with your own payment system to some
extent we like this we like not being
the customer being the customer seems
wrong but when being the customer seems
hard I ask you to think about your phone
somebody took the most complicated
imaginable device on earth and figured
out a way to make you love it
love having it love buying it can't wait
for the new one can't believe all the
stuff that can do that's health care it
is unbelievable what health care is
going to be able to do it's unbelievable
what health care could do now if 15-20
years ago the healthcare economy was
normal it's not too late to fix that
though and I suspect that we're about to
thanks very much
I have time villas I'm sorry for going
on so long so I think the problem of
public options the public option was
perceived to work the main Medicare was
so one of the things that's unique about
the United States that I think many
people who who are Medicare fans don't
understand is that no other country on
earth has healthcare paid for publicly
without a budget right so Medicare has
no budget and unfortunately once you
have no budget you set off all of this
really bad stuff
and unfortunately public option is gonna
work that way too if you talk to the
people who favor these programs what
they will say to you is it's complete
health care need is what it is
I'm completely wrong
nobody voluntarily gets cancer but of
course that's not really what it's about
right it's about how you treat me it's
about how efficient you are it's about
what your costs are how you control them
as long as the incentives are whatever
you do we will pay for you're never
going to get an efficient customer
oriented service and it's the reason for
the first slide is because the public
option is a terrific way of disguising
who really pays for it there is no way
to pay for health care without us paying
for health care and the amount of
financial engineering in health care
done by people who hate investment
bankers is extraordinary this may be the
most complex financial engineering of
anything on our society all designed to
prevent you from ever noticing how much
you pay and unfortunately the way the
public option was designed it was likely
to wind up in the same place I will
mention just one other thing which is
that health care knowledge in this
country seems to have stopped existing
in sort of circa mid 70s Europe so you
may be aware that almost every European
nation now has gone through this
enormous question of their health care
systems many are fairly happy with them
but almost all of them run into these
sort of same cost issues demand issues
there they're willing to explicitly
ration through waiting lists and all the
rest and saying no to procedures any
observer of the US political system
knows that as soon as you say no to a
senior to someone
to someone who took the public option
all it takes is a particularly
competitive election for somebody to ask
at the iowa the des moines county fair
of a presidential candidate can you
believe they wouldn't let me have my
hair surgery and that's back on the list
and i think one of things that's unique
about the united states is we are highly
unlikely to let government programs ever
say no to us in most of places that's
worked government programs been able to
say now Singapore is the only system
that says fundamentally in every
transaction the patient is the consumer
Singapore for those of you who know has
an excellent health care system and
spends under 4% of GDP on health care as
a result so it's a very good question
clearly question gets at pharmaceutical
grown enormously and public programs
have been particularly unwilling to use
volume buying to drive discounts and
pharma the problem I think in most of
this is that we've got to be careful of
doing static analysis which is so we'll
spend 300 to 350 non-farm on this year's
billion the problem is arguably the
growth of former should have
significantly reduced healthcare costs
if I told you in 1965 that most chronic
conditions were going to be treated by
pills that have zero marginal cost
instead of going to see your doctor
every month you would have said
fantastic I mean unless you of course
would doctor you would have said
fantastic right that's not what happened
we have a non-functional functioning
price system throughout healthcare and
so looking just that Pharma is sort of
misleading right so one of the things we
see in the price system and Pharma that
that's most confusing to people is that
you know the minute something goes
generic the price collapses because of
course there's no marginal cost limit
you have competition based license but
what I think is more interesting is that
me to drugs if they're on patent enter
the system at a high price
not at the generic price right and that
tells you something about how resistant
how reluctant not just Medicare but also
insurers are to drive price they're
relying on them to drive price you know
is now accepting 50 years of failure as
well maybe they'll be better next year
which is sort of what the Affordable
Care Act hopes we need a functioning
price system interestingly in pharma and
just forgive me for going on so long but
it really is interesting farm is the one
area we're seeing major shortages
Ezekiel Emanuel wrote a piece about wow
we're seeing shortages and lots of sort
of old drugs and gone generic and but
often have very important uses maybe if
we agreed for a 20% price rise people
would start making them again well of
course what you want in a price system
is flexibility when things are in
shortage the price should go up people
start negative again and as long as
you're gonna say as Ezekiel does nothing
hey you know I've just said it wrong let
me set it here you're basically dealing
with stop clock pricing right it's right
now it's definitely gonna be wrong
tomorrow it might be too high or too low
infirm I think we see a lot of prices
that are too high and a lot of prices
that are too low and so we see excesses
and some drugs and shortages and others
and it only picks any of this until we
have a normal price system because
nobody is smart enough if you spent any
time looking at how electric electricity
is regulated single product same product
everywhere in country electricity
regulation is unbelievably complicated
there's an estimated 4 to 5 billion
prices in Medicare no one's smart enough
sir quarter for Medicare spent national
so right so is end-of-life care medical
care I don't know but here's one thing I
do know is that everybody in this room
is going to have end-of-life and a very
large percentage that if it's gonna be
fortunate enough to have end-of-life
when we're old and that end of life is
very medicalised and I think end-of-life
is actually the edge of the wedge for
why our concept of health care doesn't
work so the concept of health care was
like your house burning house is burning
down we need someone to I was about to
say blow out the fire there's gotta be a
extinguish the fire and someone to
rebuild your house pretty
straightforward right and our concept of
health care was you get said me the
president said this you get fixed you
get sick we'll fix it well that's not
how healthcare works but where it's most
obvious now is the enormous amount of
money we're spending on end-of-life care
because there's no medical reason for
end-of-life care alleviating suffering
is an argument certainly but what's
interesting is that end-of-life care is
something where we really see what most
healthcare is now a choice
my wife says she wants to be kept alive
as long as there's a single molecule
living I think she just wants to be that
thin you know I know people who say as
soon as I can't play a good deal of
tennis put me down there's a wide
variety of choices as to how we want to
die here's what we've done as a society
we've said we're gonna take the
end-of-life number is somewhere around
150 billion
for Medicare patients there's some spent
innominate you lived 150 red is what
Medicare asked me so actually we don't
actually have a full definition of
end-of-life care but it looks a hundred
physically knows we're gonna take that
hundred and fifty billion dollars from
all we're gonna give it back to our
seniors only if they agree to have a
medical as death we're making that
choice as a society because it's part of
healthcare right and healthcare should
be paid for but who are we kidding
those are individual choices there's no
right answer there's no right amount of
care and it's the one area in which it
makes so clear that what we assumed
about homes burning down is no longer
what medical intervention is
and so I don't think there is an answer
to the end-of-life care question that
doesn't involve individual choice and I
think the way we're doing it is saying
you know Society will pay for you to
spend six months effectively dead in the
hospital but you can't have that money
if you just want to take the grandkids
to Disneyworld for one last trip I'm not
sure that's not a good I'm not sure
that's a good choice that society's made
and I'm not sure there's any way to
solve this question in the political
realm and I don't think Americans want
this question if he doesn't decided
politically well I just think it's one
one of many symptoms of what happens
which is if you say anything medicalised
is paid for
you do have expansion of what's
considered a medical decision and that's
all I'm saying about it like here I I
don't know how to resolve it except to
have a system in which we all have the
funds to say here's how I want to die I
want to be kept alive till my last
molecule I want to be put down after
that last good game of tennis I want to
die at home I you know I don't want any
interventions I want a lot of
interventions until we recognize that
those are individual choices not choices
that CMS can make I don't think we're
gonna have a satisfactory answer I don't
know whether we spend too much or too
little on end-of-life care I don't
because it's a matter of individual
choice and preference I think well I
didn't get physically ill but I will
tell you that you know losing my father
was 82 I knew he wasn't gonna live
forever but he wasn't very good health
and I thought would happen for a few
more years and it is a loss I think
about every day I think everybody who
loses a parent thinks about that parent
every day I think that's the nature of
being loved is probably a better
question for you than for me to answer
but that's always sticks with you and
you know you suspect you're gonna deal
with that at some point in your life I
think interestingly the biggest
emotional response was my sisters
because my sister is an emergency room
physician and I think what shocked her
is that this whole thing happened kind
of on her watch and yet there's nothing
she could do about it and in these
moments she saw in a way you don't see
when you're inside the profession which
by the way huge problem of health care
is that it's all insiders talking about
this stuff but for an insider for second
to be an outsider and say wow this is
kind of all on autopilot if I a
physician can't deal with this how does
the average person deal with this and
this is why I talk about something all
the time that I think most people don't
think about which is customer service
you know we know placebos work in health
care why they make us feel better is
there anything about going to a hospital
it doesn't make you terrified and often
that's just if you're visiting somebody
if you're the patient I mean that
relationship between provider and
patient is so screwed up in this country
because the patient's not the customer
and screw-up in a lot of places by the
way you know if you where but when you
look at patient satisfaction in Canada
it's lower than here right and and there
it's not a matter of money all the
health care in the UK at the disastrous
it is you know look I think after my dad
died and I read our tools piece and I
told jokes to me sometimes that if he
only hadn't written that piece I never
would have written the book because I
told you know as a as a culture guy he's
like doctors have to solve this
ourselves we don't need outsiders I
think it's just shocking
if you live in 21st century developed
country just how low the standards are
and since I've joined leapfrog and
actually see all the error data and all
the plain error you tell yourself you
know this is a place where airplanes
almost never crash anymore how is this
possible and of course once we're in the
healthcare system we're so scared right
hairos right we're not great consumers
but that's all the more reason they've
got to be at least as good as the cell
phone guys but of course they're much
worse than the DMV
the person inside that system who's
really their job is really to be outside
so I think you know and her own personal
experiences are small by definition so I
can just tell you from my own
perspective what I've learned as you
know and recently as that as the father
of a kid who needed emergency surgery
what it's like is that this is the
institution in our life that probably
requires us to be most skeptical most
questioning most unwilling to go with
the flow and that's a very difficult
thing because it's a time of anxiety and
certainly the culture of medical care is
a lot less Imperial and detached than it
used to be but still is more than most
other professions and I guess the two
great roles that I see you can play is
as an outsider as a loved one is to be
the skeptical advocate to kind of be the
squeaky wheel and by the way it's one of
the reasons hospitals run terribly is
because there's tons of squeaky wheels
because there have to be and that means
poor allocation of resources but that's
a system we're dealt with as patients
and then I think the second is and it
was shocking to me my father was a
physician and a psychiatrist my father
and my mother had never talked about
end-of-life care and he was 82 and part
of it of course when you reach 82 is you
don't want to think
I don't want to think about it at 53 and
of course the 30 it's inconceivable
you're gonna live forever so I have the
conversation but interestingly I think
one of the roles you can serve is really
to recognize that healthcare is about
personal preference in many many ways
chronic conditions cancer increasingly
are about how do I want to treat this
aggressive do I want to be how much do I
want to sacrifice quality of life for a
potential quantity of life is often a
case there's obviously a lot of
bioethics issues that are complicated
but I think to be the loved one who has
a best sense of the individuals
preferences and values is an enormous is
an enormous value you serve not not just
if the person becomes incapacitated
incapable of making decisions but just
to have someone to talk to because the
system itself isn't great at this
conversations they don't they don't
you're still a patient so you know my
perspective is very heavily the business
person's an economics person and I meant
what I said before which is I've met
since I started doing this I've met a
lot of near saints and they're the
problem they're a huge problem because
they prevent us from seeing the problems
in the system you know oil executive
comes in here and says you know the best
thing for this world is cheap oil it's
an important argument worth listening to
we're thinking about but you said
yourself well that's how his company
makes money I get the connection makes
me skeptical doesn't make me
uninterested that makes me skeptical
health care folks get the chance to say
we know what's best for you this isn't
about us it's about you and for many of
them it's true right which is a big
problem one of the best Hospital chains
in the country is guy singers in central
Pennsylvania president loves them lots
of health care guys love them and I had
dinner with the guy who runs guys
singers and he said you know the
president views us as a model for other
hospitals and since I'm a very
diplomatic I said less terrible idea
right there that's the worst idea I've
ever heard right that's like saying the
model for our junior high school
basketball team is the Olympic dream
team right you're LeBron and you know
you're Dwight Howard it no we're not guy
singers went out and paid a ton of money
and hired some of the best people in the
country so that's not an option for
everybody right by definition that
doesn't work that works if you can
afford it you have protected monopolies
like they do what we need in health care
is those things that enable the mediocre
to achieve above average results and or
above results that we have today and
that's why I focus on economic
incentives you know there's an episode
of The Simpsons where Homer is required
to supervise employees and he's
absolutely no idea how to supervise
anybody he says are you guys working
hard and they say yes sir and he says
could you work harder yes sir well that
doesn't do it what you need are economic
incentives and I think what you need is
because people have economic incentives
in health care they're just point in the
wrong direction
my cardiologist gave up Medicare this
year something conceivable for a
cardiologist do so quarter of his
practice so Mike should probably a third
of his practice Medicare patients
because of a super kradic oath he's
gonna see them for free he still has a
better deal getting away from all the
rules and regulations of Medicare and
seeing 2/3 of his practice outside of
those rules and one-third for free so
that's bad incentives that doesn't work
right and we don't allow a price system
to operate we don't know how anyone to
make money by being cheaper and better
and more accessible until we do until we
allow those real competitive urges to
drive what people do every day we're
relying on they're just working harder
and being better that's terrific in your
hospital it's terrible across 5,000
hospitals just has no meaning and that's
what we're stuck with in healthcare now
I think sir
so it's it's the ultimate I think
society question when we move from a
focus on health care which is where we
are now to a focus on health and I think
your statement is completely correct one
about policy and priorities at a
national basis over the last two
generations we've shifted 15% of GDP and
are proposing doing another five from
everything else in life much of which
effect prevention and health to
healthcare imagine a town that said you
know we're no longer gonna invest in
fire retardant materials we know we're
going to teach people fire safety we're
not willing even gonna tell kids not to
light matches we're just going to have
the biggest best fire department in the
world
that's we've done that's a social choice
we've made
well because it's it's a system in in
fairness it's a system that believes in
internal discipline that professional
boards can in Turkey and effectively
eternally just one and the rest of
everything else we believe in external I
completely understand as I said as in
leapfrog we have to do we get all this
data and we try to figure out what the
factor of underreporting is it's it's an
enormous but I just want to get your
first question for just a minute because
I think keep in mind that the bulk of
spending in this country going forward
on health care is going to be on chronic
conditions and keep in mind that the
percentage of Americans who at some
point their lifetime will be diagnosed
with a chronic condition is a hundred
hundred percent we'll all have one part
of it is we've relentlessly expanded the
definition of chronic conditions
relentlessly right we now have pre pre
hypertension it's a chronic condition
look it up right why there's a pill that
treats it too now chronic condition the
choice we've made is that rather than do
the things that make us healthier I take
a stab thank you all for paying for part
of my statin
right if instead I chose just to eat
less meat and fewer doughnuts and
actually worked out a little bit you all
wouldn't have to pay first that it's a
Seidel choice that was you'll pay for
the stop and we're doing it in
everything and you know nobody wants to
be ill everyone wants to live well but
let's remember the social choice we've
made will pay for the fire department
not for the fire retardant pajamas
so so so the Cystic sigh did about
different countries lifespans once
you're an OECD country so once you're a
rich country then number one variable it
looks like in variation in lifespan is
education
so there's there's a couple elements of
that right one is that the government is
experimenting with changing
fee-for-service with bundled payments
it's a long conversation I actually
don't think it works because I think
bundle payments actually make it easier
to hide costs and prices right I mean
interestingly enough in the rest of the
economy
your ability to bundle indicates market
power being required to charge fee for
service indicates a lack thereof but
Medicare under the Affordable Care Act
is paying something called accountable
care organizations bundle payments on a
per capita basis for their patients and
then the idea is the accountable care
organization if it can spend less money
on that patient then the average
Medicare patient gets this but the
savings and arguably they share it with
their physicians and other it hasn't
worked in the first year I can if we had
another couple hours I can tell you why
it's probably not going to work at all
because in fact it runs if you were an
economist not a health care economist
you would recognize that countable care
organizations or local monopolies local
monopolies do not mean prices go down
but they don't understand market power
they think they've made it more
efficient the other aspect which I think
is more interesting on which I'd like to
end with if I can is what I call the
accidental genius of affordable care so
I think the affordable care act that
almost everything wrong
almost everything wrong and and they're
not because we don't want people to be
covered I'd like to see universal
catastrophic health insurance but
because almost every problem it's solved
by making it worse
because it lives in this health care
bubble this island of health care
economics interestingly though one of
the great unanticipated consequences of
the Affordable Care Act is it almost
everybody in this room is gonna have a
high deductible insurance plan and far
higher deductible than we thought right
so high deductible the corporate world
meant $1,000 for an individual $2,500
per family the administration's been
very stingy with the data on the
exchanges but it looks like significant
percentage of people are buying $5,000
high deductible plans unfortunately
those areas where you were most likely
to have price competition preventive
care and contraception have been removed
from deductibles which will actually
make the cost of them higher I know many
of you don't understand why but your
cost of contraception will go up
enormously because of this you just
won't see it you'll think it went down
and those were the areas will
competition
best chance of driving prices down but
interestingly unless you get a serious
illness in this country outside of
preventive care and contraception most
of what you pay for health care is going
to come out of your pocket which means
all the stuff I'm talking about is
likely to happen because if you're a
provider you save yourself almost
everybody who walks through the door now
as a paying customer now I have to tell
them the price cuz they're gonna ask and
maybe I have to do a deal with them and
maybe I have to lower my prices and
maybe it's cheaper to see me in the
middle of the day than it is during
primetime hours and maybe I actually
become like a business I think a lot of
good things are gonna come out of that
it sounds terrible it sounds awful oh my
god I got to pay $5,000 a year for my
health care an addition insurance but it
was coming anyway
cost was already there it's just now
it's in your hand what I finished the
article the Atlantic with would like to
finish with now is imagine a Medicare
system like Singapore's who instead of
Medicare paying the hospital they paid
you and you paid the hospital you were
the customer do we really think they'd
kill a hundred thousand people a year in
hospital acquired infections if I had to
go to my mom and say here's the bill as
opposed to go to Medicare I don't think
so anyway thanks so much for tonight I
really appreciate you